hey what's up video game fans daniel
dwight here with justin haywald and
we're about to make some goddamn mario
this is mario make well super mario
maker super when it came out it was just
going to be shoemaker yeah this is
actually a super mario maker have you
have you played this at all have you
tried it
but you guys have had this uh in your
office for the past couple days it's the
best week about now yeah and it's been a
bunch of people going in there laughing
and screaming at the television and then
walking out again uh i watched you and
randy play a little bit uh we're gonna
play here for about an hour uh on uh
this year live stream uh how have you
enjoyed it over the past week or so
since getting your hands on it it's
really good i mean it and it's basic
that the premises you are making mario
levels it comes with some preset levels
and and some things that are baked in
but all the i mean the main crux is that
you are going to make your own mario
games like so this is the the main menu
when you open it up super mario maker
you either make or you play got it uh
it's like we can just jump in and start
making stuff so you can see some of the
things that are available go for it whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa cat paw what oh new
notifications
and so so i made some levels earlier and
you can see like some people are gonna
interact with the like so i can see how
many people played each of the levels i
had i have a jumper and another level
called what goes up must come down when
people star your level you get to see
that
you get to see as people play them which
is kind of neat a lot of people play
this the first level i made which is
called tutorial and is really shitty
no one ever starts that one though
as you get anything from them like
starring is or is it just like a rub on
your belly so when you first start out
the game you are able to to make to
upload 10 courses you can make and just
upload ten things uh but then with as
you get more stars it unlocks the
ability to do more of that i haven't
made a lot of very good levels
apparently right so i don't have a lot
of options yet so this is the creation
area so this is this is about a week
after playing everything unlocks them
the longer you play but not within a day
okay uh the longer in terms of like
things you do or in terms of minutes in
terms of things you do and in terms of
minutes oh wow okay so this is the full
menu of stuff that's going to be
available to you to create with but at
the beginning all you have is this this
one bar at the top okay so each day you
play you play for about five minutes in
this maker area um and then it'll say
it'll cue up your next delivery for the
next set of stuff and then the next set
of items will come down like all of this
number two comes down then in one go or
did they do a piece meal sometimes it's
piecemeal and there are also other
little things that you'll see around the
screen that you might not see when you
first open up the game like over here in
the right hand corner you can say how
how long the level lasts oh wow if it
has an auto scroll and how fast that
auto scroll is
uh
here's this mario so
the mario in the left hand corner like
you can start playing a game at any time
and you can see here's the path that i
just took if i go to edit that
i can see the path
so like to help you
so for me looking at this and probably
for everyone at home who's seeing this
for the first time it seems like there's
a lot of stuff on that screen it seems
like there's a lot of like information
to take in you playing this over the
past week has it like is it okay has it
been too much information or
nintendo are usually pretty good at like
you know tutorializing stuff like this
so that's as i was saying at the
beginning almost none of this is there
in the game which
i mean when you're trying when you want
to review the game and when you want to
try out as much as you can it can feel a
little frustrating but from the point of
view of someone who's like trying to
figure this out it's it's actually
really smart the old literally the only
thing you have at the beginning is this
row of items and you don't have anything
else to play with you don't have you're
you're starting in super mario brothers
world one
and you only have this this is the only
thing available to you at the very
beginning of the game you unlock
different terrains uh and so you have to
play you have to play around with the
creator in order to unlock this kind of
stuff and to get new things and like
it's
the more you play with it the more you
realize what you can do with it but it's
also it does limit what's there like
it's almost a crazy thing to come at
from hey everything's unlocked you can
just do everything yeah there are some
things missing like this is not
literally everything in a mario game you
don't have every creation tool ever but
you do have a lot and it's even not
limited to what you see in the menu here
so like let's say you pick bowser here
so this is the row that has bowser i'll
drag and drop browser down to the side
can you is that the fault or can you
like change that to be a different hand
oh yeah and you can change your hand so
that's a cat different cat some dogs
mario pointer
you have all sorts of different colors
so you can match what you're going to do
great okay yeah i guess everyone's going
to pick the cat anyway so you might as
well be a dog go for it team dog so in
some of the items if you shake them they
turn into something else so there's
bowser jr
turns back into big bowser and you can
see what he looks like in the different
versions of the game so here's new super
mario brothers
wow
or if i want to go to super mario
brothers c here's super mario there's
three bowser shake them again it'll turn
into junior bowser jr
are there specific worlds in which like
when you shake something comes up that
maybe there wouldn't be another one so
some items are specific to each world so
uh
so like
let's see in this mario you have the the
feather like right that's only used for
flying in super mario world if you go to
super mario brothers 3 it turns into the
tanuki leaf oh cool okay go to super
mario bro the original super mario
brothers just becomes this mystery
mushroom okay the mystery mushroom is as
they showed before is the thing that
lets you
put an amiibo into the game that somehow
that works if you so if you take an
amiibo you put that onto the game at any
time i brought mario so it's kind of
useless
right there's a mario amiibo that you
can turn yourself into
can you
can you use any amiibo in this game
i think i think they've pokemon in there
and stuff i think they've said you can
use any amiibo we haven't tried it out
with literally everyone i'm pretty sure
you can
all the ones we've tried so far have
been able to have you tried non-mario
amiibos
a lot of the smash ones work there's a
there's a level in here that's kind of
done with some pokemon like lots of
different pokemon amiibo
okay that's pretty wonderful so it's
it's like crazy so and this is all just
kind of thrown together every time you
open up the game you're gonna be able to
see uh a level that it's kind of thrown
together that you can start playing
around with and here's something that uh
that i've already put together i was
especially proud of this one called what
goes up so i can go ahead and load my uh
what goes up must come down
how long had you been playing the game
by the time you made this one this is my
most recent level so this is after about
four days okay do you want you want to
give it a try sure yeah yeah yeah sure
okay god put me on the spot oh no is it
scrolling
so one of the things that we haven't
talked about and you hear like there's
this heartbeat coming yeah
one of the really cool things is the
vitality sensors no no you you can add
sound effects and things as you're going
through this is oh wow this is gonna be
sadness oh god you son of a [ __ ]
am i gonna have to do this every time
so
oh oh it's gone all the yeah i don't see
the okay so here on the left-hand corner
there's the frog hit the sound effects
and now these are sound effects that i
put into the game which is kind of a
weird placement so you have these hearts
over here that give this that thumping
sound uh if you jump onto the uh the
ones with the feet there they give it
they make it say ow
and at the very bottom as you go through
the
as you go through the winning portal the
heavens will open up and they'll shine
light on you
oh wow like these kind of weird little
touches that you can throw into a level
both to let people know like oh you're
on the right path you're doing the right
thing or yeah that's not what i want you
to do or in this case like these the
thumping hearts like just give it a
sense of foreboding hey give me an argo
give me another go i can do this i can
do this this is something i'm going to
channel my inner eric tay
and just imagine that i'm i'm playing
some sort of cat mario nonsense so this
this is definitely a difficult one there
i feel like there's got to be a way to
make levels more vertically higher
there you go
um yeah so like it's just a ridiculous
level of
customization and one of the other neat
things is you can add sound effects that
are your own voice oh wow so like
danny sucks
so anytime i can put this anywhere in
the game so when mario passes by that
area
don't put it there at least there i've
like done something
so if someone else plays this game
online is that gonna if they play it
online i don't think the voice part
actually goes through that seems like
nintendo's terms of service would have
that one locked it seems like yeah that
would be that would be a problem and so
this is the editing mode so you can you
have a lot of
justin's you're not actually gonna uh
you're not gonna die you're you get the
chance to just pick up from wherever you
are and like to tweak the level to make
it however you want so like oh we can
make this a whole lot easier just by
moving stuff around
that's not going to help make it easier
oh yeah okay move some of them move
these around like oh no i didn't i don't
really like the placement of that this
one's already uploaded like it is
possible to get through this i made it
not an impossible level and people have
yeah people have made it through i think
nice you got a lot of extra lives there
so the reason i put extra lives uh at
the bottom
no mario what am i talking about so one
of the other so we can get out of here
and see one of the ways that you can
play the game so it's not ju it is about
creation and sharing your levels with
other people
but you can also go into this world
channel the menus are a little bit crazy
but there are different ways to
experience these courses you don't have
to just like go through and try to find
stuff yourself the game is going to
throw them out for you and one of them
is this called the 100 mario challenge
and you do easy normal or expert okay
so this is just pulling on easy yeah so
i'll do a new game it's gonna pull 10
random levels wow you have a hundred
lives to get through it okay how does it
know which ones are easy and which ones
are hard
i don't know exactly like it's it's some
kind of algorithm i think based on how
long the stage is how many obstacles are
in it but also as people play it i think
it'll like
move it up or down right so like the
amount of attempts to the amount of
successful victories whatever they can
sort of gauge it so if the level yeah
level like seems really long but people
are like everybody who plays it is able
to get through it it'll probably get
moved down in the ranks closer to easy
so this is just a stage that somebody
made
it's on the easy side it should be on
the easy side
people seem to really like new super
mario brothers uh you in using this
who's playing this at the moment because
obviously it's not out you're here well
i guess a lot of review there are a lot
of international people playing it so
one one thing as well is that the stages
that you see here even the stages that
we've created
you're not going to be able to play with
them like this
this is a special review server so
they're resetting everything yeah
so everything we make is also completely
useless here we go what you got there oh
yeah star
and that was pretty easy
so in the upper left-hand corner you can
see like oh i've earned three mushrooms
but i can only have up to 100 lives so
you're never going to earn more than
that
and you can only earn three in a stage
even if you keep failing you don't get
those lives until you get to the end so
you could burn 50 lives getting trying
to get through this and you only get
three back at the end and you might get
three bucks you watch okay if you've
earned them wow so so
how have you been dividing up your time
playing this then has it mostly been
making stuff has it mostly been doing
these uh challenges is there any other
sort of way in which you can play that
doesn't involve challenges just like
random
level picking or
browsing yeah there are ways to just go
through and look at some of the the top
levels the way place things are rated
you can look for friends and by people
i'm really showing off my skill here
get that coin while you're there
oh
there you go
do that wasn't a swap between pallets
like halfway through is there anyway you
can't swap between pallets but you can
make levels larger and larger so they're
not always just gonna be one screen you
are able to eventually unlock the
ability to like go through a pipe and
open up into like an airship or an
underground world or that's pretty close
um okay so i'm not somebody who plays
games like little big planet to make the
levels i'm part of the 95 percent of
people who just play stuff
uh
for i guess context do you tend to make
stuff in these games
or is this something mario makers like
taught you i am so not a game maker i'm
not a game designer and and mario really
teaches you
that you're not a good game designer uh
one thing is like i i've really enjoyed
playing through these different levels
uh like when i started out i was just
like oh i'm gonna jump in i'm just gonna
start making levels and seeing what's
out there but but really playing levels
has kind of helped teach me what makes a
better level right because you see how
shitty some of these are you're like oh
god i can do it can do so much better
than that it's like you can go into
courses as well and just like here here
are the featured ones in in these review
servers you can look at them by star
ranking
up and coming
it's a good that's a good loading
animation and so here you can also see
like 79 people have cleared it or 79
people have given it a star like they've
said this is a good level 276 people
have played it these numbers are of
course going to be much larger win the
game the game's not even out right right
right right right right galagas is
killing it right now
he makes a lot of levels some are good
some are bad another one mind your head
winners don't use shrooms that's pretty
cool oh this is this is i tried this one
earlier and so that's another
interesting thing about the game is that
it can
change the way that you play mario games
so this is a real pain in the ass level
because you're not supposed to collect
any mushrooms okay you can't get through
it
so that's a recent point great start a
lot of people and then you can see those
little red circles are where everyone
else died oh really
that's great
so you have to play through this level
by not getting mushrooms
and if he's up because you can't get
past otherwise there's another there's a
part later on where you'll be trapped
well you can just get rid of these guys
make this a little easier on myself
so that's great take some damage now i'm
small again i should
ah i almost had it let's
that are very very different which is
cool that gets really interesting
to be able to think about it in a very
different way
ah tough one you got it
yes
hey walt
oh jesus whoa
living by this
sea of your pants there are those are
those comments left by people then yeah
so like french genius
i don't know can you read french yeah i
have
good i don't know what rhee is
jae
so you see like oh i can't get past this
point you have to be small mario to get
through here you can't even slide
wow
like you go
try one more time
genius
so can you leave comments anywhere you
want as well is it
i keep going
are they vetted by nintendo as well can
you just say
you suck man
not that you should are you going right
you're tapping he's writing on your
little
wii u gamepad here
you're writing what am i doing is yeah
tapping oh yeah you can't see on the
screen
what am i doing
okay
there you go send it
oh wow there's like a spoiler tag as
well you can use
if you don't want to you don't want to
spoil people's
uh experience content entered
successfully
cool i wonder if that means that they
have to oh no there it is what am i
doing
oh back you go that's great
so presumably
they're like the best people have like
the best times as well on this one
i i haven't seen a way for you to record
scores and times yet oh really
is there any speed running aspect to it
then to these levels or is it mostly
just oh you're [ __ ] here mate does
that
you always have to like set that whole
area up so let's
see if this is i don't know if that's
doable yet
oh this is great people are going to
come up with like the cleverest ideas
this is already what they're doing all
right try one more time yeah you got it
don't worry we're going to be here for a
little while
don't worry there are
unlimited like this is so this is
probably more in line with uh super
mario brothers 2 not right not the super
mario brothers 2 that came out in the us
the uh the lot what came out of the us i
think is the lost levels did you guys
get that in the uk i don't know i wasn't
iowa i have full disclosure i am not i
grew up playing commodore games so my
mario appreciation came years years
later my first first marrying ever i
ever bought myself was a sunshine
actually so
yeah so here we've we've made it to the
first checkpoint we've gotten through
i can't go through that way you have to
you have to go through this so new super
or super mario brothers 2 the the the
game that was released in japan
was like an [ __ ] version of super
mario brothers
super mario brothers 2 like was based on
doki doki panic the one that we got here
in the u.s but then they they made like
an expert
they made an expert version of super
mario brothers okay and it had things
like invisible like you'd go to do a
jump and there would just be an
invisible
block there okay so kind of
in the in the vein of cat mario as some
twitch viewers would know today have you
ever seen cat mario i've not seen cat
camera is basically [ __ ] mario
it's like
fake
fake blocks and like i've done this
before so i noted this oh god just stay
there nice
oh but it's not gonna matter because i
don't think i can get through this point
of course you can just none of this
oh yeah hey i'm not setting myself up
for horrible feelings that's great
just go up there and scoop them while
you're there i'm gonna go i just wanted
to get that one too all right
so as most of that is most of what
you're seeing so far that type what the
hell there's this weird mushroom that
does that i haven't unlocked that one
yet i don't know works friggin waluigi
mario or something
that's the same skinny mario
yeah that's
that's terrifying ah
what's going on
i think so they're constantly spawning
are they spawning upstairs as well
you almost had it
there's something about the aesthetic
and like the sound and experience of
mario that makes replaying this like
totally fine like it's kind of calming
in a weird way
you're still with a familiar soundtrack
and
so you can also like you can take levels
that other people have made and then
kind of play with them and edit them
although i don't think you'd be able to
upload something that you borrow from or
take from somebody else okay
but it's not like when you're playing
you can't change anything on the fly
oh
whoa so i can't just like make this
super mario brothers 3 because some of
the items are tied specifically to how
the level and world is created
all right i don't remember after this ah
at least you're in
idea but do it a few more checkpoints
that's what a loser says that guy's a
loser i don't need to get rid of
keep getting them
what if at the end you won because you
picked up the most mushers
that was that was it all along what are
you doing here i'm terrified
i'm seeing what else is around so i
can't go any further i have to go back
it's a good idea
for pimentos
where are you going he's got a whole you
were kidding me
oh my goodness wait not the whole way
back down that way do you
go all the way back here ah
i did shroom and passed
says that person with broken english oh
my goodness [ __ ]
what's the longest you spend on one
level
uh i know i've i've the first time i did
this level and because i've done this
before i timed out
like trying to figure out like oh what
did you want me to do and then finally
figuring out oh no you really did mean
don't collect any mushrooms because i
spent a long time just trying to get
around it i was like oh no it's a trick
i love how it just spits out one every
time just to mess with you
look at that jerk
oh my goodness
i'm keeping an eye on the chat there if
he wants to uh have any questions for mr
haywald uh please by all means i shoot
them in there
my goodness
how much is left you only got two
minutes
on the timer buddy
what am i doing
you just lost your focus completely
spit out three more
i i've burned so many on some levels
like i know i've lost like 50 lives on a
single level
so like some of them are good some
levels are put together really well and
you're like i know i can do this one
more try one more try and i can get
through it
oh and some levels are just complete
[ __ ] levels
all right good
game time now 90 seconds
here we go
here we go
oh that's the worst it's almost like
it's almost out of your hands it's like
the way you jump in at the start is
now that's that's just because i suck i
can do that uh gaffier is asking uh
what's the cost of this bad boy full
retail game 60 bucks what are you
talking about this is a full retail game
um what am i doing
and does it feel like it
yeah like there it's it's a mario it's
like the best of mario plus infinite
level why what why wasn't it out there
oh god
i thought it would be further down
this game's a real i'm gonna run out of
solid troll
oh there's plenty of that
uh what's the hardest love you've seen
so far folks asking for you to play
expert
expert is it's so oh it's so
mixed and we can do that after this sure
we got 30 seconds left of this then it's
gonna get turned into real hell i've
i've spent hours playing through like
expert levels and it's oh dude you did
it again i know
it's it's been a long it's friday it's
been a really long day already oh we're
gonna
we're gonna die
didn't make it
i have i have passed this level i don't
think this is i don't think this was one
of the expert ones
five seconds where'd you want to die
just get actually get killed by that
plan
they'll kill me first time's up so we
can go over to expert expert has it's a
mix so okay we've definitely gone in
easy we've seen some of what you can
create with a little bit of time
expert is is formidable
and it's it's just nothing but unending
sadness
so i mean i guess to give us something
to work towards yeah by the way like we
could through here you can also like
search featured you can uh
sort these by where they come from uh
what kind of difficulty they have yeah i
don't want to play no more french levels
it's like global
location time period when they're
created expert but there's part of the
100 mario challenge is also
uh
no of course world
the menus are
are weird the menus are
a bit funky nintendo e
so go over here go to courseworld and we
can do the hundred mario maker challenge
on expert okay
sure
so presumably you can like stop the
challenge and come back to it right yes
not like an endurance run or anything
of course is that where we're
at i go back to the menus on expert mode
now
i get lost sometimes in the menus i've
been
too many too many shrooms play
not 10 mario 10 mario challenge is super
easy that's different
that's the easy one oh i'm sorry there
it is there you go 100 challenge on
expert
so an expert you have 16 levels you're
like especially if you go through easy
you go through normal you're like oh
yeah yeah this is totally doable
expert takes it up to several degrees
higher of of sadness and frustration
some people have heard me in my office
just screaming they're like oh is justin
playing call of duty 2 no no no
he's playing mario in another castle man
look at that
all right let's see what the first one's
like the first one can't be that hard
right no well so that's the thing is
like this is totally random you're just
playing 16 random stages they could
start out okay okay you don't know what
you're going to get they could they
could start off with something that will
make you burn 30 lives wow on the plus
side you can skip a level whenever you
want
that's really pretty this was made by a
german person
look at that
all right let's
oh
esports justin haywald
oh that's amazing look everyone died
do you know what the bigger ones are
the bigger there were some bigger like
x's where people died i think that just
means a lot more people die there oh
that's cool
you got this you got this got the rhythm
got the rhythm got the rhythm oh
oh look at this [ __ ]
yeah
that was a pretty easy one nice work
well lackey twos were taking it easy on
us
i had not seen that that was that was
nice i like that that was pretty sweet
and there's a good variety feel it's not
just the same like three or four tricks
in every level no it's it's you never
know what you're gonna get some
sometimes it's complete [ __ ]
and so sometimes it's really good and
interesting and then it'll be mixed in
with pois uh puzzles like people have
found ways to like make many puzzles
right out of the games well i guess with
the whole
mushroom thing even that was kind of a
puzzle of its own as well you're gonna
die when you jump down aren't you
why would you do that
because it'll get you
all right serge
is that a bit annoying do you have to
drop back to that screen every time you
die
it seems like that would might
do my head in a bit oh bullet bill
oh okay
yes gotta take that one right
i don't think so i think that was just
a lot more people died apparently doing
what you did than
the opposite interesting
i think people forget how slidy mario is
like you you slide around a lot on the
ground after you land
and people forget that i'm oh
it's too good got a frame of
invincibility keep me alive
and then
presumably all the other
all the other different versions of
mario like the physics are slightly
tweaked then right like i said my
world's gonna feel a little bit
different
oh yeah a little bit different do you
think is mostly consistent between them
i think mario is a very consistent
series in terms of uh
how gameplay feels between it or what
are you doing justin oh my god i hate
you
how it feels between different
iterations
no no no why did you do that
see before this sort of shame was in the
comfort of your own
office which now it's been broadcast to
the
rest of the watching world
if you ever do get too frustrated like i
said you can skip i'm gonna i'm gonna do
this when i see a little bit
if you skip it will you still be in the
challenge you'll have to do another
number it just changes the level like if
you just feel like this level is
complete crap is there any way of
bookmarking it for later then kind of
being like oh can you do that are you
genius
although that actually might not be an
advantage here you probably want to be
small right
oh look at that
someone's going to jump off isn't it so
i'm just going to pop in and out
oh
no
oh god uh group she's asking who the
best mario player in the office is
peter brown peter all right
it would be me or peter brown
everyone else is so young they didn't
play these games growing up
randy
no oh my god randy's so bad
he doesn't have the young excuse either
no offense right now
young heart
you have to do it you got too close you
have to keep going
well yeah no i'm like i'm at the end now
you can totally it can totally make it
cynthia reckons guys just pretty good as
well oh yeah that gadget is good yeah
he's played oh
just go just go
game over bro oh wow
oh that was cool that was close
worthy effort
89. don't worry you got plenty of time
left so like i love the i actually like
the sound like that you think that it
might do your head into to see the
the mario marching at the end of every
one but it's it's kind of interesting to
see
them get smaller and smaller
and hearing the the march of your own
mortality
oh are you looking for that one
all right there we go
okay careful that bullish there's a
bullet coming down as well just hold off
for a second maybe he'll i'll make it
before
oh
look at that
i don't think that i don't know if
that's what it wants you to do
but i was not like that you he might
have wanted you to surf across the
bullets going right wow we're not going
to do that no
that's ridiculous too hard for me serge
we're not going to star that
church
so his fault so that's the
surge the joy that i take in these
levels is going no i'm not going to
start that you can't dislike something
and i wish you could so much
you just won't endorse his good work
like amazing like what am i getting into
you don't you don't know what darkness
awaits you it's so weird going from
that
oh jesus
whoa ah you were
channeling come on come on
jeez
[ __ ]
oh no
oh
i thought it would hurt me but i would
still go through i guess not it's really
weird jumping from like
super old nes mario to new super mario
it's like whoa jesus you don't even
realize how
good this stuff looks oh oh only two of
them
jump jump
jesus crap
i didn't need to jump
oh
and not knowing how long it is as well
it's a bit uh a bit crazy a p-town giant
asking uh what's the most fun game mode
for you guys what are you enjoying the
most you enjoying making enjoying the
challenge enjoying random searching
levels
enjoying dying
is is
as masochistic as it is i do uh i i love
just playing levels playing the
creations people have made oh what
i don't know
i guess i accidentally skipped it
accidentally eh oh well
on what
does this one someone put in the link
amiibo i guess
okay we've seen these before like this
isn't totally new oh what
what no
you jump over the top
oh my god that's so cool
just let that
no don't come back up here
i love the idea that you couldn't even
do this sort of stuff in the nes version
like there's no way that it would have
been able to process oh maybe it's stuck
maybe indeed
maybe you're stuck
oh damn it
nope nope nope nope
oh god this level sucks
oh my god
there we go this is so like visually
upsetting to watch we go
all right here we go
i love the idea that suddenly like
streaming on the wii u is going to get
really popular just out of nowhere
jesus christ i think i think we can get
through this i think
this is not confident now
oh god there's a whole situation
happening over there on the right man
i'm not sure
careful
well
he's gotta kill him he's gonna kill you
no he's not so he's not gonna come out
of the pipe while you're on it the
problem is that as soon as i jump off
and start trying to kill goombas he's
gonna come back and i'm not gonna be
able to go to the safety of the pipe
right so i have to kill every goomba
while i'm out
esports east forte walls
don't [ __ ] die in like the most
benign way possible now
no this isn't bad jesus man i'm
yeah he's justin haywald
first trump applause first try
bravo the production
staff in the back the crew
give me a round of applause so i guess
it was okay that we skipped that last
level jesus christ yeah anytime you can
just hold select and get through a level
oh man and then we're only at four
playing the expert levels on expert 100
challenge or just going from one level
to another what do you prefer 100 mario
challenge like this gives you something
to work towards
like i i really like that i i like what
is this i don't know this
like playing through levels on experts
like oh that's interesting but like
this really gives you a reason to to
keep going
to not give up all right
dude so the messed up thing is like i
so many of these like baddies and like
power-ups and stuff like i know lots of
them because of like later mario games
and stuff
and i've played these games
bit by bit but i never didn't i didn't
grow up with them so like i'm looking at
this [ __ ] like
almost thinking like it's a totally new
type of game like somebody's bodies are
like what the [ __ ] clue what's going on
here
oh what the hell there we go
no show yeah bowser why not
you gotta face your fears
respawn
don't shoot fire don't you fire don't
you fire
jump jump jump no i can't do it when
he's going backwards
are we going to run under him
i have to
but he has to be moving
if he's moving backwards he's just going
to land on you because there's not
enough speed distance oh my goodness
cavemania
so when you start the game how many like
pre-created levels are there
i'm not totally sure it's like i plugged
into the internet as soon as i got in
um it seems like there's a lot of
content
baked into the game
uh
sorry it's hard to talk in like no work
it seems like there's a lot of content
baked into the game and some things
unlock as you're playing through like
you get sample levels as you unlock uh
different pieces of content
like how many different sample levels
have you gonna come across
like you know ballpark kind of
i i i would guess probably at least a
hundred oh wow okay oh what
what
okay
um oh [ __ ] did you is there another
invisible something there maybe
yeah
climb that phallic
thing
yeah you heard me tie
oh there we go
that make you big oh no turns things
into the see this
is this is the mario i'm lost at
yeah fire flower
oh it's so nice when people give you
power-ups
catalog of errors there run see what
happened is you got the fire power up
and then you're all like
cocksure and it all went wrong
what a disaster so you can't set save
points there's no like mid point save
that you're able to as in like if you
were creating levels yeah you can't okay
so super mario world in particular
had those kind of save points that you
could put in you can't do that
is there can you string levels together
i guess this level kind of is in a weird
way because the doors but
can you string levels together in terms
of like you you go to like an
underground area
you don't well yes you can do that in
terms of like the way the map like
within the same game you can go from
here to a an underground looking area
[ __ ] you
um but like not in the in terms of like
having a full game and then over to
another full level you don't seem to be
able to do that right
uh scroll back likes that bowser's new
tactic is to just
uh ambush you out of nowhere that would
probably you know showing up in the
middle of a stage oh
you got killed by that stupid little
beetroot thing
what do you call those ones uh goomba
that's not a good that's a goomba in
this one yeah that's what they look like
little mushroom goombas yeah so like a
kind of rounded so different to yeah i
never played this i never played this
one
i'm sorry this is what this is one of
the best mario games that's what combos
look like in this jesus
all right
like they do look a bit off-brand right
like comparison
they look like some fake ass
they are different looking super nario
brothers like maybe great gianna sisters
oh
no no nope nope
nope
let's get out of there
i was out it was getting a little cocky
that was my fault
oh that's why because i hit my head too
uh so it's fair to say that like the
i guess the entertainment in this game
is based
very much so on the user created levels
which is kind of interesting right
nintendo have never been that confident
with online creation whereas it seems
like fundamental to the enjoyment of
this game i'm not i don't think of
myself as a very good creator of things
but i think it is a lot of fun to create
things as well to create things in this
in this game like i feel like i can
create pretty good looking stuff
without without a ton of time oh chuck
them in there
you're genius
you're a genius
yeah i'll take care of that's so
satisfying oh you you've made a bad
choice there
you also might be stuck no i can get it
all right
get that bill
go away ghost
i believe that's called a boo boo yes
yeah i get that
so what are the different mario games
we've got in here we got super mario
so new super mario bros u or wii u uh
the original super mario brothers super
mario bros 3 which was the nes one and
super mario world which is
this world yes
um
and but elements
in is the world is the one we were able
to jump on yoshi for the first time yes
okay so is that in this as well
yoshi's in this game when people want to
throw him into worlds
oh god damn it
you were doing this first time over and
over again before
well it's like
we had
i did have the uh
the benefit of the the enemies below it
before
to help me
to have something to bounce over
come on
all right and more questions in chat
little snow i'm not getting any more
mushrooms
james big mac saying oh good lord make
this jump
sakamura this jump is so easy lol
sakamoro why is he making it so hard
just to give you some uh encouragement
yeah you know despite the fact that the
last level like when you one shot at
that ridiculous level
there i got it now i get to die
oh all right here we go
we're back here again
not gonna die easy not gonna fall into a
bone
dry bone those guys are called dry bone
dry bones
i know those i know them well from the
world of mario kart and remember what
happened last time
you'll be careful oh look at that you
nailed it
that was just lucky
so if you make your own luck in this
world justin
here we go here we go
it's a bad the game is a balance
sometimes you have to take it slow oh i
could have i should have saved him i
could have opened we have no idea what's
in there could have been something good
yeah take that stupid hamster oh dude
you're in the way what's the hammer
thrown guy called again i think he's a
hammer brother i'm a bros there we go
okay get that boot can't get rid of the
boost oh god damn it just like life your
ghosts they're just they're always going
to be haunting you and those bones go
through the wall
this is a whole hell of a mess this is
fine
oh
what's next
oh jesus oh no whoa careful
oh yeah you're at the end
justin haywald
oh no problem
you got three back
i wish we were at 80. they couldn't have
taken 15 because i wasted a lot at the
first level oh yeah we spent a long time
me wait just going back and forth
cavemania give him a good start
that's a good one
leave a comment
you suck
i don't know how they're vetting the
comments i haven't seen a lot like
nobody i haven't seen any penises
drawing anywhere no penises in the coins
is the miiverse still a massive bath of
people this is
a lot of nice things
actually the uh the post uh iwata
is um sadly early death they had a lot
of really cool and nice little poignant
uh drawings up there which were pretty
pretty rad
this one's i could have just run for it
that's a that's a plant there on a on
trampoline
that's kind of
oh
hitbox
hit yeah hitbox
triple jumps three one up and i'm
playing counter strike 1.6 here
here we go
oh yeah
that's so good
like what how is why would you do that
how often does that happen it's way too
often like do you almost just like
assume now
that there's gonna be some you have to
sometimes hope that there'll be
something beautiful and that you want oh
oh oh oh
this one sucks cause you're not that was
giving you like any like your dad won't
touch your dad there's no like mushroom
right at the start or like that
that that was my fault though i blamed
me for that that because that was an
easy one see
when it's easy when when when you do it
right you make it look easy that was
pretty that was that was an easy one
that was like of course cool you were so
we're getting through these no star for
you portugueser
you
87 lives right level line six you're
gonna do it have you ever done you've
done before no expert one i'm not be an
expert at all like i always i choke at
some point later no no no
yeah this is
i always ch i have not made it through
on expert yet
so we might not be able to show what you
get if you unlock uh like there are some
things we're not allowed to show yet oh
really okay
embargoes so if we get through we might
have to
oh
god damn it that would that was being
greedy
hamsters man
all aboard
i'm just not cool i'm scissors are
hamsters varmints
yeah that's important yeah
don't vomit
i saw two possums fighting outside my
house
but i've never seen a possum before
terrifying
oh [ __ ]
that was luck i didn't deserve that
believe in yourself
get those one ups
oh so i can only you can only collect up
to three one ups right
i didn't jump far enough so right now
like now i have all three one ups so you
don't get them until nope yeah i'm gonna
keep losing lives until i get to the end
have you gone back and played like
regular ass mario since you've started
playing this no because you're probably
just going to be like amazing at it
right
all right just like this this
you know well early mario is all it's
like it's pretty easy
all right those are all ones
not those
guys
i didn't open up the one on the far left
before so would they be anything worth
taking over it could have
it could have been good
for the level
like the only thing you take out of
levels is lives presumably right yes but
i mean it could have been a
oh jesus
what
it could have been what no no okay okay
okay yes oh god thank you
nice work it could have been a mushroom
which would have made me feel a lot more
confident going through the wrenches
we'll start that that was
that was nice nice work nathan
on the board from the netherlands
i think
wow
oh 88 lives you're almost there doing
good this is
pretty good there are no shortcuts in
life
okay oh jesus oh no no well that star's
gone so you're boned come come
back my god
so you have a lot of you have a lot of
jerk levels like that where it's just
like yep you need to have you need to do
this immediately
there we go yeah [ __ ] that seems like a
shortcut in life
coins don't matter in this game
like that's one thing you you learn did
they just use them to like
people like you people who make good
levels use them as a guide all right
so is he being passive aggressive to
this guy
this jerk doesn't get it
just put him in a willy no no no no no
oh bro oh bro oh this is
[ __ ] oh
it's like i hate you
oh
you're very impressed with your ending
of the last level
very clutch oh i will
disappoint you all before long oh why
did i why did i give it up have you seen
any um i don't know it might be
difficult uh
this early on but have you seen any like
the one thing that happens with every
level creation tool in the world we had
like little
big planet or
whatever no no go go go go
oh
you got him first time right now time
you gotta you gotta
you came out maybe
just like teasing matt
oh [ __ ]
or maybe i can
you think nope can't make it
it's just too high it's just just that
right point to make you
sad other followers little mario's go in
a row uh yeah i'm sorry like i was
saying that like the the third the sort
of thing with level creation tools is
that everyone always makes one one no
matter
no i've seen a few one ones have you
seen anyone do the opposite and sort of
take you know do homages to
other non-mario games in this
there's been a metroid i think that's
been cheered around a bit
there we go oh yeah using the cloud oh
yeah oh run right off the cloud even
nintendo are on board
i'm terrified so i'm just gonna jump out
of nowhere oh yeah
there we go that was jay hizzle
no shortcuts in that one i don't know i
don't i don't understand that level no
star for you
what kind of theme is that where's he
from american figures other steve's
all right how many more you got seven
left
that's pretty good eight and we're on
level eight is this a good demonstration
of the sort of breadth of levels that
you get in
super mario maker
okay i like this already
uh yeah like in being able to make weird
things
so even though i'm mega man i don't like
i'm not able to shoot i don't have any
mega man powers or anything oh
so presumably whoever made this level
has the mega man amiibo right yes so are
there any rare amiibos
like is there any amiibos that don't
have the same circulation as somebody
who collects amiibos justin haywald you
should know the fire emblem ones okay
and do you think all of them do you
think how many of them do you think are
supported
uh
who knows
okay good have you tried it didn't work
i have we don't have a lot in the office
though but did they all work for you or
did some of them not work i think
they've all worked all work so far
i have pretty basic ones oh no
there was a big one see see that guy
could have been a jerk he could have
made those spikes on the bottom but he
didn't
what a nice guy
oh no the squid dude's gonna get you
are those yeah so like this is a good
mix of so we had a water level above
that was a ship level
that's fine
this is this is going to be harrier
there we go
this is going the other way
oh
oh my god my heart oh no
oh i didn't realize he's not alive
i thought you're wearing some sort of
suit
are those like cheap chips for
underwater
oh
screw this
no no no no no
so far
it's a bubble man okay so he's made like
his own
mega man
homage bubble man stage okay so like
you're starting out okay i see it like
you're starting on the clouds this is
this is bubble man's stage
in mega man
it's pretty good
oh that was my phone
i'm lucky
that's pretty good that's a
that's a good homage just like we were
talking about
stevie mongo's hates water levels with
those jellyfish
there any way you can filter out content
when you're searching can you like
search for like i want to play games
like
play levels that like use the amiibos or
like i want to play only
mario
like original mario levels or stuff like
that i don't think you can get quite
that granular
it sounds like you wouldn't want to
either though right
yeah that's ah
like you're generally looking more for
uh
like either difficulty
yeah it doesn't seem like you can filter
by theme but i i think the cream seems
to rise to the top the really good
levels
get thrust up
frost up that cream
there you go now just losing it early oh
you get greedy after you you're playing
for a while
have there been many levels that you've
just said i'll [ __ ] it and skip oh yeah
i've played for so many hours
oh that was i thought
that thing isn't where you're like well
you get fire and you just you want to
rush past it to get to the bit where
where you died the bit where you're like
i know i'm gonna have trouble with this
oh my gosh oh you got another one i'm
sorry
they want to make sure he stays
in theme stay on point
on brand
megamouth so cute
she be made that's like a chubby mega
man
you can do it you can do it
we believe it i believe in you
don't let us down
yeah this guy's gonna get in the way
at least they give you extra ones as
you're going
not knowing how far you are from the end
is infuriating
now we know we still have to get through
that
oh this whole situation
ooh
esports justin hey well audrey got stuck
yeah damn it
oh my goodness
we'll give it one more go one more
i believe in you
gotta believe
the chat believes in you you can't see
but it's just full of
ball of game spot members just
not saying how much i suck no and how
much i
need to give up on life i hate me wow
that was that was
really just
yeah and that's your last chance on that
one nice work all right uh let's uh
let's check out some of the other little
features uh anything we haven't shown of
uh super mario maker
um just looking at random levels maybe
or do you want to show some more of the
creation stuff
yeah we can jump back into creation we
didn't spend too long with that
and see what kind of we could we could
crowdsource a level sure yeah good show
all right let's make one
with all uh the viewers right now
can we name it together so i think to
start off with we need to pick the the
mario the theme okay so we have mario
brothers mario 3 mario world and mario
yu
and then we have the different levels we
have grounds whoa
underground
underwater nope
ghost house that level will be a lot
easier on the water i will say that
airship
oh that's so cool and castle
wow
any preference of your own oh you're
gonna blow it up
you did it you did it
all right we're waiting for mario 3
underground let's come in
from dc amber first one
although hot cheese 25 says ghost house
what do you think
airship
well mario 3 ghost houses never i don't
think they existed no no just ghost
house
i don't know what what mario
is that ghost where are we now
so this is what it goes said and so the
the the creation tools that you work
with change based on what mario you're
you're in and so they kind of adapt so
like you're using the clock popped up
so you're just doing this on the you're
like basically swiping on the the pad
here i'm just like painting the level
weird noise it's making you're moving
with your left thumb stick basically
move the left stick right with the the
right
it's so weird the noises
and you can fill mushroom blocks with or
coin blocks with anything it's like
let's start off with the night oops
no that's good
it's like a tetris level
and we could put a
turtle in one
oh but put a
tanooki leaf in the other
is it true then you can like put like a
like a mushroom in there as well and
it'll make them make the
like the bad guys bigger
so it's not the
you don't you don't want to do it
beforehand so like let's take that out
shake it to take it out let's say that
we want to put in a super-sized flying
turtle so by shaking him you can also
make him a red shell or a green shell
turtle and so that affects how their
their ai works
and if i grab a mushroom just stick that
on him come on that's cool some wings on
him
that's awesome
now he's in there too
that's pretty good
so you can also play with like these
tracks and
and so any pretty much anything can
float along the tracks even if you take
a bowser
let's take a bowser and super size him
so now we have one super size floating
bowser
he'll go left or right oh wow god it's
so
user friendly it seems
that's amazing
ah that's crazy
super intuitive
my very tutor says
wrecking effect
oh yeah it's like this this part of it
is just really easy to do
and it's cool like
it's cool that like little elements of
the stages will pop up as you're playing
like the the things that add to the
ambiance of the level the
the clock and the the background
elements
let's paint with some other stuff
oh you can have like bowser's floating
thing here
and you can put you can mix and match
things in in weird ways like if you want
to put a a wiggler inside him yes like
he's he's piloting it
show me a move show me a move
that's cool you just top the bottom left
corner whenever you want to jump between
the two
bottom left is
edit and play and you can try out what
you just did
see how
things look or or how they're playing
and then if you want to put that online
like what's to stop you from just like
putting up some like awful crap like how
does it work
nothing's going to stop you from putting
absolute awful crap
but let's say let's say i want to do
this you can't make something impossible
or you you wouldn't be able to say like
i'm just going to be an [ __ ] there
you go try to get through this
impossible wall because when you go to
like let's save it
if we call it impossible ghost house
it'll basically say now you have to play
through the level before you can upload
it oh wow so everything has to be
completable by at least you yes that's
interesting because then that means that
also like people who make crazy
difficult levels
that's the other thing that like
encourages you to keep playing
like just saying somebody else beat this
at least once it's like let's say oh
let's try and upload this level my hard
level you need to clear this course
before i can upload it clear the course
now
we'll we'll know can i have a go
i'm going to try do it i'm going to do
it justin
whoa
so we start off really good because
you're in the middle of the wall yep
classic uh mario trope there being
spawned inside of a wall
got my tanuki suit so i can instantly
get hit by bowser
don't worry about me bro
no
i'm gonna jump over you you jerk just
jump in him you can knock him out no no
no he's just mad never mind
oh yeah no it's all red i'll just jump
wait a second
you son of a [ __ ] this isn't clearable
this is [ __ ] nintendo so yeah he
can't upload it that's pretty cool
oh that's awesome
oh and it's gonna make you keep playing
that's it
it just locks you in until you've
completed this
and then that's the end of the game wow
that's awesome uh anything else before
we wrap it up here mr haywald i see
anything else really that stood out cool
like
like as we mentioned the items and
different things change depending on
which mario you're playing as
so even but but enemies that didn't
exist in some other games will still
exist within this world so
um let's see like
well i don't i think this one might
change so like here's this uh the boot
guy
uh he didn't exist in any of the other
marios but if you go to regular super
mario brothers ah
there he's like oh he's a
boot guy
contributing to a high school name it's
like hoop guy no it has a there's a name
for it
oh and that that turns into yoshi in
super mario world and new super mario
brothers you
very cool god it's crazy just flipping
we've seen them all
super sized yoshi
it looks so much more janky
that is
it's like a lot it's like a 3d bowser it
looks it looks like three times as dumb
i i prefer the look of the
of the other
of the other bowsers
especially mario worlds bowser like so
cool yeah he's really scary super mario
brothers 3.
yeah he just looks like a dork in that
one he's like mario
i'm gonna get you when i was a kid i
always thought he was clapping but i
think that's supposed to be like his
bracelet it's like oh yeah it is you're
right yeah like his armband and he has a
bracelet but i always imagine like he's
clapping yeah it says i'm gonna get you
but that's the that's the base game
that's what there is in mario maker um
and as much fun as you're going to get
out of it is both the nostalgia of of
seeing these mario worlds and being able
to create
whatever whatever you want to be able to
try to be a mario level creator
but it's also like that's the end of the
game it's not going to be at the crazy
level of something like a little big
planet where people are making
calculators or they're making a shooter
within the world of little big planet
like you don't have that much
ability to affect things but
many of those are always interesting to
see but not really that interesting to
play it was so hard to make yeah like
that that was so much beyond my level
but like with it with this especially
the more you play the more you're like
well hey i could make a level kind of
like that like maybe i could do a little
bit better and i think that's what's
fun about this game is that the more you
play the more i want to try and create
things that either fix those problems or
that have my own idea or like my own
spit like oh what if i could make a kind
of puzzle that's not the way that you
normally play these mario games that's
awesome oh yeah and you can use the the
buttons to so this is a multi-grab tool
if i just want to take
all of these yeah and now move them as a
group oh that's cool or copy yeah the
interface has seemed um pretty amazing
actually
of all the things probably the most
impressive uh scene so far uh just
mayweather thank you so much for coming
on today's november that was a lot of
fun yeah thank you uh last thought on it
obviously it's coming out september 11th
just a couple of weeks away yeah
interesting day good times um
what are your sort of final impressions
of mario maker what have you what do you
think about it uh after a week of
playing it is it something that's worth
a full price i want to spend some more
time with it but
it's definitely the kind of mario game
that i want it's so hard to live up like
i didn't like new super mario brothers
you that much and
it's hard to really live up to what you
want out of a mario game but this i feel
like it has the potential to be whatever
mario game you want and like that's what
makes it a lot of fun it's both stoking
my nostalgia like i want to play a
really hard mario level and this lets me
do that in both the style of those old
mario games or kind of a new style but
also being able to play new things that
i didn't think about before and be able
to experience mario mario in in kind of
a unique way and this feels like outside
of going with you know like a 3d mario
galaxy kind of world this is the actual
evolution of mario and like not new
super mario brothers you or any of those
where you're just playing through
somebody like these other creators
versions of like slightly tweaked
graphics and trying to improve on it
that way like no just give it give the
power to the people like and making you
the creator and from that sense i think
it's really exciting it's been a it's a
lot of fun and i can see i can see
myself spending a lot more time with the
game awesome well for continuing
coverage of super mario maker and of
course the review around the time of
september 11 when that comes out stay
tuned to gamespot.com stay tuned as well
here for more now playings and we'll see
you next time
you